nun haben wir hier bei bild unter
anderem wir ganz kurz berichtet über
diesen sogenannten ehrenmord an mariam
zwei täter mutmaßliche täter deren
brüder die afghanischer herkunft sind
diese männer werden aktuelle lage
aufgrund des abschiebestopps zu
afghanistan in deutschland bleiben
finden sie das gerecht ich finde hier
sehen wir das bild der beiden verzeihen
sie ja scholz mit dem koffer in dem die
leiche von maryam sich befindet die
beiden sind mit dieser leiche mit diesen
koffer quer durch deutschland gefahren
machten sie das gerecht erstmal finde
ich solche morde fruchtbar und es sind
morde an frauen man muss das auch ein
film eat nennen ich will das ausdrücken
hin zu sagen das darf man nicht als
irgendwas
kleinreden nach dem motto kulturelle
traditionen oder
familie oder gottes bewegung sondern ich
sage ausdrücklich dass es aus meiner
sicht eines der schlimmsten verbrechen
das überhaupt begangen werden kann
weshalb ich auch dafür bin dass solche
sachen in deutschland hart bestraft
werden und das habe ich gesagt auf
nachfrage nicht nur ihre zeitungen aber
auch ihrer zeitung immer wieder und
anderer das ist aus meiner sicht völlig
klar ist es solange wir in länder
abschieben können wir das auch machen
und das gilt dann auch für diejenigen
die hier schwere straftaten verüben wie
zurück wenn das jetzt nicht mehr möglich
ist ist das in dem fall etwas was wir
zur kenntnis nehmen müssen wenn sie
könnten die ausnahmen machen für solche
schweren straftätern dass sie bei denen
sagen da schieben wir in solchen fällen
nach afghanistan ab wir werden wir
werden alle länder in die wir abschieden
immer regelmäßig überprüfen und für mich
ist einfach klar dass man sagt es ist so
dass wir erreichen müssen dass
diejenigen die so etwas tun kann ist
nicht sicher so stand jetzt herr scholz
noch mal um das auf den punkt zu bringen
wir haben in der tat in den vergangenen
wochen ja immer wieder diese frage
gestellt in diesem fall ja sie haben
immer auf die gesetzeslage verwiesen die
aktuelle das machen sie hier ja auch
aber es heißt er für den konkreten fall
die beiden brüder bleiben in deutschland
und das finden sie aktuell richtig finde
dass ich finde so dass in eine situation
eintritt in der wir sie dort wieder hin
abschieben können was jetzt die nächsten
jahre aber sie bleiben stehen hier das
ist das ist so dass wir das auch tun
sollten
und das ist ja das was jemand der hier
recht und ordnung als wichtiges thema
hat auch nur machen kann aber wir werden
genau das immer im blick haben ok und
das wird auch im aktuellen wo das malz
bestätigen dass ich es richtig dass die
beiden brüder nach ihrem sogenannten
ehrenmord in deutschland bleiben dürfen
ich finde dass sie bestraft werden
müssen ja in deutschland und ich finde
sehr klar dass wir eine situation immer
herstellen müssen wo wir wenn wir
abschieben können das auch machen sagen
sie ist einfach also es liegt ja vorhin
sie können ja sagen ich finde das
aktuell richtig weil wir eben nach
afghanistan nicht abschieben wollen
aufgrund der sicherheitslage dort
deswegen müssen die in deutschland
bleiben ich finde das aktuell richtig
sagen aufgrund der gegenwärtigen lage
können wir wenn ich das sehr klar sagen
das ist selbst mit unserem eigenen
willen nicht bewirken dass das geschieht
da reden ja manche auch sehr groß
sprecherin steht eine keiner weise dann
die frage beantworten können wie sie das
überhaupt machen wollen und ich finde
man sollte auch nicht
eine klare haltung
irgendwie unklar erscheinen lassen meine
haltung ist klar wer solche straftaten
begeht muss damit rechnen dass er auch
den aufenthalts anspruch in deutschland
verliert und wenn es aus den gründen die
bhs sind ein bisschen abzuschieben ist
aber bei den sie auch nicht möglich
deswegen das ist meine haltung das ist
eine harte haltung das würde ich dazu
sagen die ich auch gegen das haben sie
in hamburg deutlich gemacht in der tat
in dem konkreten fall danach fragte ich
aber bedeutet das ja die mutmaßlichen
täter die sogenannten ehrenmorde bleiben
nach scholz' halte oder diejenigen die
ihn dort zu schauen sind ja kluge
vernünftige leute und die wissen dass
man das machen kann was man machen
wolltest ja ich wollte so klar verstehen
ich will deshalb auch sagen sie haben es
gerade gesagt ich habe mich sehr dafür
eingesetzt dass es keine schwierigkeiten
gibt mit dem abschieben des wurde in
meiner verantwortung eine abschiebe
einrichtung am flughafen in hamburg
errichtet die vorher gar nicht da war
und ich habe auch auf den weg gebracht
dass es zusammen mit schlüssig heute
schon hin den man in der abschiebe
einrichtung heute daran im moment nicht
abgeschoben da waren einige versteht man
das abschiebegefängnis versteht ist
notiert wenn da das verstehen ist es
erst mal verstehen ist es sogar schon
vor dem gespräch und ich sage es auch
laut und trotzdem hätten sie sich so
einfach machen können und direkt auf die
frage beim ersten war schon antworten
können ich finds aktuell richtig dass
die straftäter von maria in deutschland
bleiben aufgrund der aktuellen
sicherheitslage antwort gegeben die
richtig ist und nicht die eben nicht
finde das auch den jungen zuschauern
finden dass sie dann nicht versuchen
diesmal so wahnsinnig kompliziert so
verteidiger fällt schnee habe ich aber
nicht ich hab sie
in dem ergebnis dann korrigieren sie
mich die beiden straftäter der leitung
der aktuellem stand in deutschland und
ich sage ausdrücklich die frage wie
wichtig ist es mit welcher haltung gegen
den an und die die ich habe und die ich
wiederhole und die immer wieder meine
praxis geprägt hat ist das wo die
möglichkeiten dazu bestehen das auch
geschieht und hofft schon sich jeder
verlassen